hallo herzlich willkommen so salis welt
heute gibt es eine richtig leckere
reispfanne und zwar ist die reißleine
sogar vegetarisch aber weil ich dem rat
eine freude machen wollte gibt es dazu
noch so dass das stück wollte ich bin
ich sogar mit in der pfanne verarbeiten
aber ich hab dann gedacht nee kommt
wir beraten uns an weil es ja wirklich
schön kross und knusprig wird und
deswegen gibt es das ein extra ration
das heißt wenn ihr eine vegetarische
vorne machen möchtet dann lasst einfach
so gut weg wobei morath jetzt sagen
würden ein dass das nicht weg dass ich
voller geschmacksträger die pfanne
besteht aus reis ich habe zwei
reissorten gemischt und zwar will dreist
und naturreis man sie zu wem du gehört
der partnerwahl stolz auf dich und ich
habe noch kichererbsen mit dabei das
ganze schon ein bisschen orientalisch
angehaucht und wirklich sehr sehr lecker
ich zeige euch mal gefordert die zutaten
für die reispfanne brauche ich 150 gramm
bildreich das ist so ein schwarzer reis
eines lebe drei esslöffel olivenöl
ich habe ich noch paprikaschoten und
zwar zwei gelbe grüne und eine halbe
rote die übrige für die haben wir
gegessen
250 gramm braune champignons ich habe
ich noch 150 gramm naturreis eine dose
kichererbsen sind etwa 480 gramm
ich brauche ungefähr 900 milliliter
flüssigkeit dann nehme ich gleich selbst
gemachte gemüsebrühe
ich habe ich eine zitrone davon brauche
ich den saft einen teelöffel salz hier
habe ich noch ein viertel teelöffel
kreuzkümmel ein teelöffel chili und auch
einen halben teelöffel pfeffer ich habe
ich bereits einen halben boden
petersilie fein gehackt und hier habe
ich noch so drückt es sind 250 gramm
ich habe jetzt den wind reißt bereits
abgewaschen unter fließendem wasser und
der wildreis passt wirklich sehr gut zu
herzhaften gerichten und wirklich sehr
würzigen gerichten und ich finde gericht
so ein bisschen daran riecht wie so ein
leckerer thema also wirklich sehr
aromatisch und ich werde ihn jetzt
mischen mit dem natureis passt auch sehr
gut zusammen und der weltreise es ist
die frucht von wasser gräsern um wurde
früher von den indianern geerntet also
wirklich sehr interessant und der schon
ein bisschen härter hat auch eine
längere garzeit daher gebe ich denn
jetzt nachdem ich hin gewaschen habe in
einen topf mit wasser ungefähr
und da wir jetzt für etwa 15 bis 20
minuten vorgekocht die zettel habe ich
jetzt bereits geschält und fein
gewürfelt und ich gebe das olivenöl in
einem topf und da sollte möglichst groß
sein darf gleich eine große reise pfanne
wird und das öl kann ich jetzt bei
mittel hoher hitze erwärmen und dann die
zwiebelwürfel darin anbraten und die
zwischenzeit nutze ich jetzt einfach um
die paprikaschoten in scheiben um die
paprikaschoten in streifen zu schneiden
und die champignons in scheiben
die zwiebeln sind jetzt angebracht jetzt
kommt das restliche gemüse dazu und der
reis kocht jetzt auch schon seit 15
minuten ich lasse jetzt einfach noch
weiter köcheln bis ich hier soweit bin
jetzt hat er noch gut bis und ich denke
dass er dann einfach mit dem anderen
reis wirklich sehr gut auf den punkt
gegart wird
schmuggeln wir noch ein bisserl gemüse
und moritz pfanne und das gemüse wird
etwa drei bis vier minuten mit
angebraten
jetzt kann ich denn wild reis dazugeben
und auch der vorreiter den habe ich
jetzt auch gewaschen dann rühre ich die
zutaten kurz ein und kann sie ganz kurz
mit anbraten liegen bleibt
jetzt kann ich bereits das wasser
aufgießen und wenn ihr möchtet dann
könnt ihr an der stelle zuerst 100
milliliter weißwein nehmen und das ganze
ablöschen kurz verkochen lassen und dann
das wasser zufügen
ich nehme es wasser und dann noch ein
bisschen von meiner selbst gemachten
gemüsebrühe dafür denke ich auf jeden
fall das rezept habe ich nämlich schon
online-unternehmen dir einfach brühl
nachgeschmack
ich mache jetzt mal nur zwei löffel und
würzt das ganze jetzt noch mit salz
pfeffer kreuzkümmel und chili
jetzt lasse ich die zutaten aufkochen
und sobald alles kocht gebe ich jetzt
noch die kichererbsen dazu das waren
noch nicht alle haben aber nicht alle
ins holz stellt ihm gepasst so und kann
es jetzt gut durchrühren dann mit dem
deckel verschließen und sobald es
richtig kalt ich dann den herd herunter
auch mittlere hitze und lass das gericht
etwa 18 bis 20 minuten garen
die pfanne sitz fertig den herd habe ich
jetzt ausgeschaltet und kann jetzt die
fahne einfach 5 minuten ruhen lassen und
in der zwischenzeit schon mal das zurück
anbraten
ich habe jetzt hier ist zurück was
bereits in scheiben geschnitten ist das
heißt das ist auch schon geschält aber
es gibt natürlich auch so job also die
suppe wurst umgeschnitten und da ist
ganz wichtig dass ihr da vorher die haut
entfernt die ist man nämlich nicht mit
und jetzt lege ich denen die heiße
pfanne ich habe jetzt eine eisen pfanne
da ist es auch ganz gut denn dauerhafte
deck geruch danach nicht so dran und ihr
braucht jetzt auch kein fett dafür aber
da man fahren nicht leiten soll habe ich
einfach diesen bug tremsbüttel rhein
gegeben und jetzt können wir dies zurück
schreiben einfach von beiden seiten kurz
anbraten
und wer möchte kann die reispfanne jetzt
noch mit etwas zitronensaft abschmecken
jetzt kann angerichtet werden
ein bisschen der preis dazu etwas zurück
man kann das auch wenn man möchte vorher
in streifen schneiden
und weil mir jetzt eine soße fehlen
würde mache ich noch joghurt dazu
joghurt ist für mich so ein alleskönner
und da nehme ich immer gerne den
zehnprozentigen joghurt denn der
schmeckt super krems hat eine ganz
leichte säure also wirklich sehr lang
und den wird sich einfach mit salz
pfeffer und bisher getrockneter
knoblauch dass ich jetzt hier weg da ich
ja schon knoblauch im gericht habe bzw
und wer möchte gibt noch ein bisschen
petersilie darüber und dann ein klick
joghurt und da der murat jetzt leider
nicht da ist als noch bei der arbeit und
kommt erst in einer halben stunde etwa
nach hause können wir hier jetzt schon
mal probieren ich mache den anfang soll
ja auch probieren
und natürlich so job
alle probieren
richtig lecker vor allem mit dem joghurt
müsste das auf jeden fall probieren
die ist so quast die ich so ein bisschen
scharf wobei die jetzt die milde
variante ist ich mag sie gerne extra
scharf und chili kann man natürlich auch
nach belieben noch ein bisschen mehr
dazu geben aber so hat es wirklich die
perfekte schärfe mit dem joghurt des 100
wirklich alles perfekt ab falls jetzt
auch lust darauf bekommen habe dann
schaut auf meinem blog vorbei
sally blog.de ich glaube der moralisch
richtig stolz auf mich für dieses tolle
job gericht ich muss aber dazu sagen
ich musste einfach unseren zog vorrat im
kühlschrank den see der gerade hier
musste ich ein bisschen lehrern und
deswegen musste ich mir natürlich im
rezept mit zuzug aus denken dafür was
gedacht also viel spaß beim nachkochen
und bis zum nächsten mal würde sagen
dass ich es einfach meint anne und ihr
könnt euch hier war vor